[Musica]
[Applauso]
io parlo
la realtà per me è quella che riesco a
definire con delle parole
se non ho parole per descrivere qualcosa
per me non esiste
io sono una macchina per parlare
funziona così più o meno dal mio
cervello parte un impulso elettrico
scende lungo la schiena mi prende un po
di muscoli cominciò a gonfiare polmoni
si muove tutto qua un po anche nella
pancia un pochino poi prendo aria la
mando fuori la mando fuori passa
attraverso le corde vocali altri muscoli
fanno muovere le labbra fanno muovere la
lingua ed enti la mandibola si muove
delle parti vuote dentro di me fanno
risuonare le parole quando escono le
parole e parole sono io è quello che
ascoltavo a tavola quando ero piccolo e
quello che ho studiato quello che ho
ascoltato la difficoltà che ho fatto per
imparare è quel retrogusto di accento
perugino che cerco di reprimere ma fa
parte della mia storia sono le mie
patologie e la gastrite che mi
attanaglia alla base delle corde vocali
ogni tanto fa la voce roca l'emozione
che in questo momento sono
emozionatissimo si vede è stata questa
voce così che sembra che esca fuori con
difficoltà beh insomma
questa è la mia voce questa è la mia
storia
la storia di ogni essere umano è
raccontata dalle parole dell'essere
umano
ho avuto una grande fortuna
mi sono braccato da vivere parlando non
sapevo che parlare per me era molto
facile non sapevo di avere una macchina
che mi permetteva di parlare ma per puro
caso con qualche stratagemma cominciato
a parlare e ho parlato parlato parlato
parlava per tanti anni
ogni volta che tornavo a casa mia mio
padre diceva e chi ti credi di essere
adesso che ha imparato a mettere due
parole in fila non tollerava che una
persona guadagnare soldi parlando non
ero al lavoro per lui era una presa in
giro c'è un mistificatore invece
raccontavo raccontavo il mio mondo non
c'era altro mondo per me che quello che
raccontava con le parole le parole
cambiano la realtà si cammina una realtà
anche la realtà fisica cambia io sto
cambiando la vostra realtà fisica voi
non lo sapete ma le mie parole in
qualche maniera il marra hanno
depositate nella nostra memoria le
vostre sinapsi sono già mosse qualcosa è
cambiato fisicamente cambiato nel vostro
cervello anche se non volete anche se
non approvate se non condividete
comunque cambiato il vostro cervello e
quindi da una scintilla da un impulso
elettrico del mio cervello
io condivido la mia realtà con la realtà
degli altri quindi parlando in qualche
maniera contaminò gli altri con le mie
parole e ascoltando gli altri contaminò
me stesso con le parole degli altri
questa è stata la prima parte della mia
vita
una persona che parla poi una vita è
cambiata
ecco è ricominciata da calo perché una
persona che parla che una macchina per
parlare che si guadagna da vivere
parlando per cui tanto facile parlare
non faccio nessuna fatica penso altre
cose in questo momento pensosa farò dopo
cosa ha fatto ieri sto parlando per
parlare tanto
vent'anni fa mi lascia un figlio che non
parla un ragazzo autistico il cui
problema è non poter parlare meglio le
grosse difficoltà anche nel relazionarsi
con gli altri ho fatto finta di niente
per tanto tempo pensando che fosse un
ragazzo che in fondo avrebbe parato a
parlare e magari sarebbe diventato come
gli altri passano gli anni tommy mio
figlio diventa adolescente cominciassero
un po irrequieto si incattivisce perché
tu noi a lui tutti parlano tutti si
relaziona mesi grandi difficoltà non gli
va di parlare noi ma poi tanto da avere
tanti rapporti con gli altri e molto
sensibile
gli danno fastidio le persone dà
fastidio la luce la fastidio toccare
certe cose danno fastidio rumori e
sempre i nostri di ansia continua tanto
con giorno inclinato una costola la
madre amata smessa piangere io non ce la
faccio più e io mi sono preso in carico
mio figlio tommy io che parlo sono
diventato un padre che si occupa di un
figlio lo avrei mai pensato ma avrei
voluto diventare padre nella mia vita e
invece mi sono occupato di mio figlio
come se ne occupavano una volta gli
antichi lo portavano nella foresta
insegnavano a vivere a cacciare li
legavano una liana alla caviglia lo
buttavano da una torre dotato avana lo
scarnificano possa saltare nel fuoco ci
danno le armi lo facciano cacciare io ho
fatto questo semplicemente insegnato ad
allacciarsi le scarpe a mangiare a
vestirsi a lavarsi a stare per quanto
sia possibile in mezzo alla gente
a un certo punto sono accorto che sto
molto bene come un figlio sto meglio
quello che non parlava di essere
parlante per relazionate che con il
resto del mondo
mi sono costruito una specie di tana
pensavo che l'avessi costruita per lui
una tana con le luci basse che tutto
quello che tocca vera bello era
piacevole non era spiaceva e non c'era
con la sorta di idea di sintetico di
ruvido di fastidioso che ti dà subito un
senso di brivido i rumori erano ovattati
le finestre hanno triple il mondo
fornirà come isolata e mi sentivo dentro
con la casa con mio figlio tommy che la
difficoltà di parole di relazione e
sensoriale come mi sento esattamente in
questo cerchio rosso fuori non c'è altro
intuisco la vostra presenza non vi vedo
la luce in faccia uno stato ideale non
vedo le facce non vedo gli occhi addosso
non devo sostenere gli sguardi non devo
sentire l'odore delle persone perché in
questo momento non perché sia sgradevole
perché mi dà un sacco di problemi ne
mette in moto il cervello cervello
lavora tanto lavora tanto e anche 8
punto mi sono domandato ma perché sto
tanto bene con toni più sto con tommy e
meno sto bene con gli altri la risposta
l'ha data un amica mia psichiatra detto
perché se autistico come tuo figlio di
qom a danno delle stupidaggini parlo
tanto gli autisti stanno zitte no sono
gli autisti che stanno zitti notifiche
che parlano tanto fatti visitare ho
fatto qualcosa che ancora mi dicono ma
come hai fatto come avuto il coraggio
visitare il cervello nel mio ultimo
libro a in appendice 15 pagina che la
mia diagnosi di autistico e c'è anche la
foto del mio mi guardano i colleghi gli
amici ma che hai fatto
hai detto al mondo che sei matto che sai
autistico ma scherzi per creare grandi
problemi gli altri genitori dei ragazzi
autistici
mi scrivono ma se il palazzo ha detto
questa cosa i padri degli autistici
anche loro sono un po autistici adesso
una ci guarderà alla gente che come
guarderai guarderà come genitori dei
vostri figli ma guardatevi allo specchio
che sete stan e si vede e una vita che
mi sento dire che sono strano è una vita
che mi dicono che sono matto finalmente
una patente di matto posso dire
liberamente quello che voglio nessun
problema
questo mi ha creato qualche piccolo
problema devo dire ma da un certo punto
di vista mi ha dato una sorta di super
potere riesca a vedere intorno a me gli
altri matti improvvisamente li vedo come
il bambino che vede la gente morta io
vedo la gente matta è vero che sono
tanti meravigliosamente pieno il mondo
di matti e li chiamo cervelli ribelli
non posso chiamarli matti che un termine
dispregiativo cervello ribelle mi piace
il cervello ribelle qualcosa diverso
dagli altri cervelli ho cominciato a
studiare cervelli ribelli cominciato a
vedere quanti sono i cervelli cubelli
beh se vogliamo parlare di autismo ne
nasce uno ogni cento con la statistica
molto molto molto approssimativa e certi
paesi ne nasce uno ogni 70 perché e
nascono sempre di più noi domando anche
io mi domando e secondo me è una specie
di esperimento che sta facendo la nostra
evoluzione ci stanno cambiando i
cervelli i cervelli ribelli sono
l'annuncio di un nuovo cambiamento
guardate non è che siamo tanto cambiato
proprio da un punto di vista evolutivo
e milioni di anni fa circa abbiamo
inventato il pollice opponibile abbiamo
cominciato a costruire oggetti macchine
con le macchine meravigliose che a te
visto prima rappresentate le loro forme
più moderne
il basamento è partito il cantante ecco
che a parte e quindi il mondo abbiamo
cominciato a cambiarlo grande
cambiamento sono diventato un utensile
umano abbia una mamma che può fare delle
prese precise può costruire abbiamo
costruito il mondo passa più o meno un
altro milione di anni tac ci cade il
baku lum il back room e l'osso penney co
avevamo questo attrezzo sempre conto
perché perché non avevamo non avevamo
capito che a noi conveniva essere
monogami abbiamo scelto un
organizzazione società monogama non
avevamo più bisognerebbe sento questa la
lancia e resta quindi stato il secondo
grande cambiamento poi se ha cambiato i
può così sanità ai più alti più belli
meno pelosi fa un po perderemo anche
denti del giudizio tanto noi servono più
sono passati più o meno altri 2 milioni
di anni e dove stiamo cambiando
stiamo avendo secondo me un'evoluzione
molto veloce che stiamo attraversando in
maniera consapevole e l'evoluzione del
nostro cervello i nostri cervelli stanno
radicalmente cambiando ma nell'arco di
vent'anni trent'anni abbiamo da quando
abbiamo cominciato grazie ad alcuni
cervelli e ribelli che si stavano
probabilmente in luoghi che
assomigliavano più a dei garage ma delle
cantine e delle biblioteche erano dei
nerd erano abbastanza emarginati con
coop a poche persone hanno capito che in
realtà con i loro cervelli ribelli hanno
ricostruito delle macchine per mettere
in collegamento tutti gli altri cervelli
che stavano evolvendo immaginate come è
cambiato il nostro cervello rispetto
semplicemente pro dei nostri genitori lo
dice un sessantenne quindi i miei
genitori avranno 80 anni 90 anni mio
padre aveva sì e no 50 persone nella sua
agenda cento i momenti che lavorava di
più e ne possa avere 20 mila con il
quale comunque o tranquillamente
rapporti e non sono rapporti diversi da
quelli che sono gli antichi rapporti
umani il mio fratello è cambiato il mio
cervello sta processando un'infinità di
relazioni invece robello è capace a
distribuirsi il mio cervello potenziato
certo qualcosa perdo come perdono gli
autistici che in realtà hanno dei
cervelli molto complessi molto diversi
molto ribelli sono quelli come appunto
tom il cui cervello sembra quello di un
bambino ma in realtà hanno delle
capacità a selezionare quello che lo
bello il peso il fastidio della nostra
civilizzazione il sentimentalismo il
ricatto amoroso ricatto emotivo
ti amo se mi ami
vergognati con quello che ha fatto tua
madre e tuo padre di sacrificio per te
ne una riconoscenza per loro ecco questi
sono dei fili quindi per l'evoluzione
l'umanità
gli autistici non ce l'hanno questo
senso altro tristi parlano molto come me
verranno anche spiegato perchè perchè tu
c'è un cervello che come il motore di
una fuoriserie ma non ci sia niente non
sei un genio inventerai mai nulla
semplicemente di farlo muovere
continuamente perché se non si muove
soffoca e come averci dentro una cintura
esplosiva attaccata le budella potrebbe
scoppiare da un momento all'altro e
devono parlare parlare parlare parlare
sono al cervello si ingrippa e parlo e
racconto e guardo e osservo mi rendo
conto che il vero problema della nostra
società che in realtà non c'è spazio per
i cervelli ribelli quelli come tommy
hanno un atroce destino se non mi
invento qualcosa che finché sono vivo
ancora tommy finirà in una sorta di
raccolta differenziata per cervelli non
omologati finnair ha chiuso in una
stanza sedato e avrà finalmente un
valore sociale si suo valore sociale
sarà la retta di denaro pubblico che
riceverà colui che si occupa che ha il
suo core business nello stoccaggio di
cervelli diverse e gli altri cervelli
ribelli quelle che a scuola sono vittime
dei bulli quelli che sembra che abbiano
idee balzane che ragionano che parlano
che nessuno capisce quando più o meno la
stessa fine lo so perché ho girato
l'italia alla ricerca di chapelli
rowbury le vedo persone anche molto
vivaci molto loquace che parlano dicono
cose strane finiscono chiuse in casa con
i genitori con te genito verno vogliano
tempo hanno vita hanno respiro per
scompaiono fantasmi beh mi sono
impegnato perché dei cervelli ribelli
possa rimanere traccia mi sono impegnato
perché il cervello ribelle diventi un
valore ho anche scritto una sorta di
manifesto dei cervelli livelli
cominciando a dire che il cervello
ribelle non è un ribelle nel senso
antico dalla parola e quelli che
assomigliavano e briganti che i
carabinieri facciano la foto belle
impettiti col fucile in mano e quello
steso lì su una scala scannato perché
era contro la regola giustamente faceva
anche qualcosa magari di bhutto oggi
cervelli ribelli non fanno qualcosa si
butta mettono in discussione le certezze
della società questo è il loro limite
mettono in discussione la società xvi
vincerà sul fatto che tutti pensano la
stessa cosa tu non pensi come me bisogna
essere immediatamente in grado di
isolare se non pensi come me ho capito
questo capito da autistico adesso
maurizio consapevole che in realtà la
maggior parte della gente a una sorta di
meccanismo di ammortizzatore sociale
riesce a essere gentile a dire quello
che non pensa a sopportare persone che
in realtà trovi totalmente strategie con
le quali non è nulla in comune e non lo
dicono fingono di avere qualcosa in
comune perché come il meraviglioso ted
che abbiamo visto nell'intervallo la
gente ama aggregarsi nell'aggregazione
comunque c'è la sicurezza c'è la
tranquillità ma il mondo si ferma
devoluzione si blocca e per questo in
questo momento la macchina evolutiva sta
mettendo in circolo dei cervelli ribelli
risolvere i diversi sono quelli che
stanno progettando il mondo
guardate il sintomo più evidente della
contemporaneità il vero segno la nostra
evoluzione il fatto che oggi viviamo
tutti in una sorta di luogo
interconnesso e tutti abbiamo visibilità
e tutti abbiamo possibilità di
raccontare e vivere la nostra epica
individuale semplicemente uno smartphone
in mano sentiamo dei perché possiamo
scrivere il presidente della repubblica
non ci piace possiamo scrivere che il
presidente del consiglio non è quello
che noi volevamo possiamo prendere in
giro il giornalista lo scienziato il
medico chiunque non serve più avere una
qualifica avere un riconoscimento
avevano investitura tutti possono
esprimersi anche un mondo meraviglioso
mondo di passaggio
io ricordo che
ero fra i pionieri che vedono la rete
come luogo dell'eccellenza il luogo
dello scambio di sapere entrato ha luogo
dell'omologazione luogo del trionfo del
pensiero condiviso va bene mi sta bene
in un momento di passaggio ma chi l'ha
inventata la rete che l'ha inventato i
social network che ci ha dato in mano
queste protesi per comunicare le nostre
emozioni cervelli livelli persona che ha
meno cervelli diversi c'è un dato lo
strumento per mettere a punto
l'autostrada in cui cervelli ribelli
potranno manifestarsi verrà il momento
ricordo del professor umberto eco
piangeva si piangeva addosso una rete
piena di imbecilli un premio nobel vale
come un alfabeto sera giustamente non
dico di no a professor umberto eco
scrissi allora e oggi le sue ossa si
agiteranno nella tomba sentirmelo
ripetere e ora che accada questo
e ora che l'accademia si apra io perché
lei non parli soltanto alle persone che
la seguono e che stanno silenziosa
davanti a lei perché ha avuto un
investitura e loro sono soggette al suo
investitura al momento di caos
momentaneo si ridefinirà l'umanità e se
ne definirà attorno a cervelli ribelli
che il vero grande valore della
contemporaneità se in questo momento
dovessi dire quale potrebbe essere la
vera rivoluzione e riconoscimento e la
dignità di esistere e di esprimersi e di
essere considerati come persone degne di
cittadinanza per i cervelli ribelli ne
vedo tanti alcuni riescono a nascondersi
alcuni hanno la fortuna di potersi
esprimere come me in questo momento una
fortuna enorme rispetto a tanti altri
centinaia di persone che mi ascoltano
faccio un ted quello che sta producendo
automaticamente il mio cervello
attraverso un impulso eletto e
conoscendo alla spina dorsale che un
nuovo i polmoni aspira l'aria trasforma
le parole tutto questo a conosca
ascoltare e quindi un grande privilegio
altra dal privilegio perché via via
cambiano il mondo trono delle idee
singolari ilon mask un pazzo totale mate
vistosa inventato il razzo che torna
sulla terra una cosa fantastica mi
sembra la persona normale 1 che manda un
automobile a girare in eterno bella con
il suo pilota un sogno da incubo per
qualcuno ma è un sogno meraviglioso un
sogno reale razionale una realtà che
esiste lui l'ha pensata l'ha immaginata
l'ha descritto adesso esiste c'è un
signore con l'automobile rossa che gira
e gira e gira gira sempre qualcuno se ne
vedrà avrà un senso devo un giorno quel
signore andrà a scontrare con un altro
signore si parleranno anche se quello è
soltanto un manichino darà un senso
racconterà la nostra umanità
voi direte ma che ne facciamo dei
cervelli ribelle abbiamo tanti problemi
macero del i ribelli sono quelli che
risolvono i problemi sono quelli trova
una via che gli altri non vedono il
cervello ribelle come un veggente e come
un vate e quello che vede delle strade e
vedere le cose che gli altri non vedo
che ha il coraggio a causa che si mette
in discussione
che ha soprattutto una grande qualità
che mi sento di avere una volta tanto
quella di poter sovrascrivere
continuamente proprio pensiero la
propria convinzione viviamo schiavi di
una civiltà che ci impone rettitudine e
ci impone coerenza correnti con cosa con
un mondo che cambia così veloce io
voglio sovrascrivere ogni istante il mio
pensiero
voglio cambiare idea poi tre qualcuno mi
faccia cambiare idea come le parole
muovono e sinapsi degli altri qualcuno
nuova le messina psi e mi convinca che
domani o pensare diversamente non so
dire i cervelli ribelli hanno tutti
chiuso in un grande recinto perché non è
giusto che ci siano vive al pensiero
omologato sentirei di brillo dire e non
per questo mi sentirei in corrente
questo è il segno di adattarsi
semplicemente a una realtà che muta
sentirla sentirla come rabdomanti come
la sente mio figlio quando si chiude le
orecchie perché sente dei foo uscite gli
altri nemmeno avvertono con mio figlio
che si metta a battere la testa
semplicemente che c'è una luce blu
infastidisci o semplicemente perché in
quel momento non sa cosa accadrà domani
e come gli antichi aztechi dovranno
sacrificare vite umane perché avevo
timore che non sorgesse il sole giorno
dopo mio figlio si arrabatta si arrabbia
si agita in questo momento penserà a mio
padre non c'è più non tornerà io mi
dovrò sbrigare a tornare da lui perché
il suo cervello ribelle abbia la
certezza che il mondo continua ma questo
è soltanto un esempio di un tentativo
dell'evoluzione di cambiare il mondo di
cambiare cervelli semplicemente a lui
devo capire se non occorre poi avere
tanta personalità
lasciate un po dietro di cuore di mamma
lasciare dietro i valori di patria
lasciare dietro le superstizioni in una
salsa condizionare poi tanto da pareri
degli altri sì siamo civili e non è
detto che noi dobbiamo stare male e
sentire la cintura esplosiva che sta per
saltare dentro le nostre budella
semplicemente perché non pensiamo quello
che pensano gli altri
ma noi siamo cervelli ribelle
[Applauso]